it was always been a wonderful kind of
alternative to the acting because it was
did two things pay the bills and also
great therapy therapy yeah literally it
means to be able to talk about things of
us you know and whether things going on
in my life going on in the world it was
always kind of a great release
especially like in the early days with
more con it was kind of the ante more I
could do something those slightly darker
and funnier and crazier and people go so
I wouldn't just be stuck like do
something I mean totally different which
was great how is it different today than
it was when you began um on the street
corner of San Francisco
oh my back she began doing mine in New
York which is kind of crazy I mean I was
going to Juilliard studying acting and I
would do street performing mime in front
of the Metropolitan Museum and the
scariest people in the world with the
ladies of Madison Avenue we can imitate
them that this is before Botox where
their faces are just frozen like get
away from me and even the animals that
they were but it was always this kind of
thing of performing them you know they
get out and do it it was release for me
yeah but you and you did you find
instant response well yeah with comedy I
think because you you have to there's
very little stand-up tragedy just I
started off because I was also trained
in the theater I could be I could go off
mic which is my style if so a lot of
times people need the mic and be kind of
full and I'd be like all over the place
when that was my attack style and I'd go
for it and you know it seemed to be
working right off the bat but did the
training had a Juilliard help oh I think
it allowed me to do two Jews walk into a
bar it could happen and yet my gentle
friend that does pulse so what are you
doing in weapons of destruction self
destruction of courage talking about
pretty much everything everything that's
kind of happened the heart surgery I
mean the idea of even the valves they
gave me the choice of getting you know
different valves the porcine valve which
is wonderful you're already inoculated
for swine flu and you can find truffles
yes bovine valve which
as you can grab standing up and play in
the dirt how are you doing then college
kids tip you over at night and I thought
you know because you have two daughters
you find yourself getting very emotional